it is the most anticipated announcement
in America it is a question he has not
quite answered so many times were you
gonna run again sir
it's time though a yes with the formal
announcement due as soon as today the 80
year old holder of the highest office in
the world confirmed to Sky News that he
does want to do it all over again
he always said it would be a family
decision the Judgment of his wife the
first lady was key
and it seems the person who knows him
best thinks he can and he should run
again that's why today I'm announcing my
candidacy for president of the United
States it is four years to the day since
he first told Americans he wanted to be
their president
with a video that would pave his way to
the White House if we give Donald Trump
eight years in the white house he will
forever and fundamentally alter the
character of this nation and the message
then that is likely to be almost
identical again today
because while he is four years older so
little else seems to have changed it is
all but certain for now at least that
his opponent will once again be Donald
Trump
despite the indictment the Insurrection
and everything in between he is the
power behind the Republican party but he
was beaten Last Time by Biden and the
logic is that Biden is the man to do it
again his message to the American people
will be that he wants to finish the job
the question is do they want him to
polling for Biden this past weekend has
been terrible just one in four voters
would like him to run again 70 percent
do not want him to and by the way that
same poll suggests that 60 percent don't
want Trump to run either
for Democrats it's not his record his
character or his values it is his age he
will be 82 at the time of re-election
and he'd be near a 90 at the end of the
second term if he wins but who else is
there no other credible candidates have
emerged not yet anyway Mark Stone Sky
News in Washington